during this time of social distancing we
have all experienced some type of
isolation during the pandemic and it has
been really hard especially for our kids
well tonight brian we want to tell you
about a church in henderson that is
making sure
at least one monumental experience for
high schoolers
isn't taken away we're talking about
prom madison kimbrough joining us now
live from the church with more on the
very special event madison
[Music]
yeah that's right and it's an experience
of togetherness that's really been
lacking
in this past year this is exciting news
for juniors and seniors across the
valley
as students from different high schools
can come together to celebrate their
prom
all students have really lost a lot
because
of the covet 19 pandemic and
we're afraid that they're also going to
lose their prom saturday may 1st
let the dancing begin as mosaic church
in henderson is bringing back a little
bit of normalcy to juniors and seniors
across the valley
with their 2021 a night under the stars
prom
this is sort of like our last hurrah and
ccse didn't put anything together for
that so mosaic church took up the
liberty of doing that themselves and
it's
really really great there will be a dj
decorations selfie photo booths and most
importantly students from all over the
valley
coming together to enjoy each other's
company something that has become so
foreign to all of us this past
year as a senior like i've never had a
real prom
last year it was cancelled and we
haven't had like an
experience and i think it's just
important that they're hosting this and
that we actually get to experience that
before we get to graduate the event
starts at 4 and lasts until 11 p.m
and due to social distancing and safety
guidelines mosaic church will be selling
tickets for a
one hour window allowing kids to come
for an hour and then leave with friends
to go to dinner or another activity
elsewhere
this also helps keep the capacity down
and monitored when i did prom
it was such an event about the problem
it was a four hour deal where we went
and we were there the whole time with
all of our friends
and we've found today that the culture
is much different it's ten dollars per
person and if students want to stay
longer they
always have the option to buy an extra
ticket
and we will have a link up on our
website so look out for that and a night
under the stars is open to all juniors
and seniors across the valley
reporting live in henderson madison
kimbrough 8 news now
well i guess maybe the culture has
changed a lot since i went to my prom
but i remember the biggest thing was
just finding the perfect dress to wear
that night but if it's only for an hour
maybe you don't have to go all out hey
you go all out for that one hour because
i remember it wasn't just about prom
night it was the weeks leading up
talking about it the anticipation and
then the recap and
it's such an event and who you were
going to ask it's a big deal
oh butterflies when you're going up to
ask that that girl